I FOMO pretty hard
Oh my god, I can't believe that party last night.
- I know! I'm sorry I got so crazy towards the end.
No, don't even apologize. It was so much fun!
Ah, so much fun!
Oh my god, wow... That sounds like so much fun... Haha... So much fun.
I-I wish that I had been there... But I wasn't.
Oh but I did um, I photoshopped a photo of myself with you at the party last night.
It's like "it was crazy, huh?"
It's...crazy...
(awkward laughter)
You know, and I feel like it's really easy to FOMO these days,
because we can see how much fun everyone's having
on like Facebook or Instagram or Snapchat.
(notification sounds)
And more often than not I feel like my FOMO is so irrational.
Do you, Brad, take this man to be your lawfully wedded husband?
I do.
And do you, Will, take this man to be your lawfully wedded husband?
Now, do you both take me to be your lawfully wedded bestie, to the Hawaii honeymoon?
It's gonna be so much fun, you guys.
You do. You say... you say you do.
I... do...?
I... I do...
(ding sound)
No, like, even more irrational than that.
So, why don't you tell me what happened here?
He burst in here and then he just murdered both of them.
(crying)
And then he just left?
Yeah... Can you believe that?
I was like: "Hello, what about me?"
I'm always left out of everything..
A case of the FOMO...
And I feel like I'm a hypocrite, because whenever I see photos from a party I'm like:
"That looks like so much fun...
Ugh... Everyone had so much fun.
(notification sounds)
Without me.
(notification sounds continue)
But whenever I'm invited to a party I'm like:
"Oh my god, I just wanna stay home and watch TV..."
*typing* So sorry, can't make it. Have a last minute deadline. *stops typing* To watch Narcos.
What about you?
Are you, like, irrationally FOMO-ing about everything
or do you avoid social media the day after a party for this reason?
Or do you just not care because you are a self-confident, cool person?
I am not.
I am Anna Akana.
Stay awesome Gotham.
Oh, and I have some stand-up shows on these dates. Come see them, yay!
I would like to thank sir Squarespace for sponsoring today's masquerade ball.
Thy sites look most professionally designed regardless of one's skill level
and thine tools are intuitive and easy to use.
If thou decides to sign up for one year, thou will be bestowed with a free domain.
Come, post haste to Squarespace.com to start using thine free trial today,
and use the offer code "Anna" for ten percent off your first purchase.
Squarespace. Goodmorrow!